is this the roof of a majestic Beirut
mosque
no it's a Cheesecake Factory in Peoria
Arizona
Italian beach house
no it's the entrance to an Epicurean
world of fine dining courtesy of the
Cheesecake Factory
and is this the eye of Sauron or perhaps
some portal to another dimension not
exactly though there is a transcendental
quality to the chocolate caramelicious
cheesecake made with Snickers
describe these establishments as
excessive pretentious tacky tasteless
chaotic soulless obnoxious and
overwhelming but the Cheesecake Factory
is misunderstood
those giant Egyptian columns conceal
complexity authenticity and oddly enough
humility
sponsored by brilliant and Brilliant
only learn math science and computer
science the intuitive way with the link
in the description
by size The Cheesecake Factory may not
look all that impressive with about 200
locations it ranks only 15th among
American casual dining restaurants
there are seven and a half times as many
Applebee's and four times as many Olive
Gardens
but watch what happens when we compare
Revenue per location
suddenly The Cheesecake Factory sits in
a league of its own
its average restaurant generates 11
million dollars a year 76 percent more
than second place Texas Roadhouse and
sixty percent more than PF Changs
like in and outs they may be relatively
few and far between in fact there are
fewer Cheesecake Factories than in and
outs but each one is a certified money
printing machine
put differently that's eleven hundred
dollars per square foot more than Kay
Jewelers made selling wedding rings in
2014.
avocado egg rolls are apparently a
better route to riches than literal
diamonds
there are two main ingredients to this
incredible success
first this is what demand looks like at
a typical restaurant over the course of
the day from Chili's to Chipotle
during lunch and dinner customers are
easy to find in fact you don't find them
they find you
this on the other hand the period
between about 2 and 5 PM is every
restaurant's nightmare three hours
during the middle of the day every day
that are almost as unprofitable as eight
in the morning
during this window location is extremely
important customers will stop by but
only if it's convenient
the solution many Cheesecake Factories
are located in or near malls afternoon
Shoppers guarantee a steady flow of foot
traffic during this lull solving one of
the greatest challenges in the industry
sharp fluctuations in demand
the other ingredient of course is its
legendary menu
what started as one page in the 1970s
has now grown to 21 with 13 categories
26 subcategories and wait for it 250
unique items what you're looking at here
is a condensed version without the
descriptions prices International
translations company story disclaimers
trademark symbols and yes full page
cheesecake advertisements usually
scattered throughout neither it is what
you're seeing include the separate kids
happy hour gluten-free or quote
low-calorie skinnylicious menus
at 6 000 words and with an estimated
reading time of 30 minutes the real menu
is more treaties than tweet
from here opinions quickly diverge
a deep though unspoken Schism divides
the cheesecake discourse
after extensive ethnographic research
and a few clogged arteries I've
identified two customer archetypes
the first sees in the darn good 3000
calorie Factory nachos with spicy
chicken incredible value a Hearty dinner
and lunch the next day all from an
appetizer from Italian to Mexican
Chinese and American Cuisine there's
truly something for everyone
where else can Grandma order a Cobb
salad and Grandson a cheeseburger spring
roll
the other half sees a heart attack
waiting to happen
in this strange alternate universe even
a salad can set you back in 1900
calories
the average American is advised to eat
no more than 20 grams of saturated fat
per day
the classic Basque cheesecake contains
88 nearly four and a half days worth and
if all those calories don't cause a
heart attack they argue the
architectural hyperstimulation will
the gigantic portions the 21 page menu
the Collision of Egyptian columns and
Californian Palms
it's all just too much
to this group The Cheesecake Factory
represents not just gross opulence but
the only thing worse unjustified
opulence
they imagined the company as Three Olive
Gardens in a trench coat eight
transparent clumsy attempts to make a
corporate chain appear more
sophisticated than it clearly is
they enjoy the same very Cherry
Ghirardelli chocolate cheesecake but
with a certain hesitation from a
psychological distance and with a tinge
perhaps of smugness
there's simply no way all 250 dishes
were meticulously crafted never mind
freshly prepared
therefore the large menu must indicate a
lack of taste a cynical emphasis on
quantity over quality
except here's the thing they were
meticulously crafted and they are
freshly prepared
somewhere between restaurants 1 and 200
likely after going public in 1992 The
Cheesecake Factory should have succumbed
to the natural process of
corporatization
it should have shed its quirky SoCal
personality and joined the homogeneous
soulless heap of Olive Gardens and
rainforest cafes
these corporate ghosts May retain
superficial vestiges of their former
glory Olive Garden's shallow commitment
to hospitaliano but inside they've
become generic cheap imitations
would you like your mass-produced
microwaved soup served with a French
beret or a Mexican sombrero
submerged in the sea of Sami Brands who
can blame these critics for assuming the
same of the Cheesecake Factory
the company doesn't scold those who
scoff in its direction nor does it do
much to advertise its authenticity if
anything the opposite you can certainly
be forgiven for thinking food from a
self-described factory was mass produced
shockingly however it's really not
everything you see is made from scratch
not scratch with a wink really
starting at 6 a.m each morning chefs
begin preparing 700 ingredients and 160
sauces marinating each piece of buffalo
chicken shredding each block of cheese
and chopping each tomato
and because everything is made to order
the company will gladly accommodate all
kinds of customizations
try ordering a Caesar salad without
lettuce and be amazed
The Only Exception is the cheesecake
itself which is made in one of two
bakeries in California and North
Carolina and flown as far as Kuwait and
China
now does its hilariously large menu
allow the company to attract more
customers and thus generate more profit
of course nobody's claiming otherwise
but every last one of those 250 meals
are delicious and they aren't chosen by
focus groups or in corporate boardrooms
instead the founder law school dropout
and former rock musician David Overton
now 76 years old personally approves
each one
other companies pay lip service to
inclusivity with half-hearted
low-calorie gluten-free and vegetarian
choices only to cut them when costs
increase
after all rule number one when it comes
to profitability is less is more
fewer options equals less complexity
lower costs and faster training
in 2021 60 of restaurants reported
reducing the size of their menus
IHOP recently dropped a whole 10 pages
Dave and Buster's went from 40 items to
15. even McDonald's switched to a
limited menu
The Cheesecake Factory on the other hand
maintains its mind-boggling Cornucopia
of 250 choices replacing but not
removing a dozen or so every six months
to keep things fresh
a few are practically sacred like
Evelyn's favorite pasta named after
David's mother and the original
cheesecake unchanged since the 1940s
gaze into The Surreal dreamlike Abyss
that is the Cheesecake Factory Ponder
its dizzying success and tell me what do
you see
if the image staring back at you is that
of an insecure teenager sporting a
briefcase and an oversized suit it's
only because the illusion of
carelessness was so seamlessly executed
The Cheesecake Factory is so confident
in its taste freshness and quality that
it rocks the oversized suit with ease
it willingly unnecessarily chooses to
expose itself to ridicule for our
enjoyment
it's not a careless chaotic corporate
commodity masquerading as fine dining
it's fine dining masquerading as a
careless chaotic corporate commodity
tragically this modesty has robbed it of
its place in a small Pantheon of lovable
corporations
now is the Cheesecake Factory weird
objectively
but its weirdness is a product of its
role a Melting Pot
it lies at the intersection of blue and
white collar America a nice dinner out
for the working class and a fun if
slightly ironic Indulgence for the
middle class
it's low calorie gluten-free and over 40
vegetarian choices scream come one come
all and its strange palette is the
result of an indiscriminate Fusion of
Cuisines from Tex-Mex egg rolls to
Cheeseburger spring rolls
finally The Cheesecake Factory is the
ultimate American export forget about
the Statue of Liberty or 20 million
dollar f-16s
85 countries and territories host
American military bases
19 are major non-nato allies
but only the most privileged a small
Elite circle of ten have the honor and
distinction of hosting a Cheesecake
Factory Canada Mexico Bahrain Kuwait
Qatar Saudi Arabia the UAE China Hong
Kong and Macau
these culinary outposts shining beacons
of American decadence multiculturalism
and abundance are as effective an
ambassador as any of its embassies
movies or pop songs
today's sponsor brilliant offers a no
less impressive or diverse menu of
courses on everything from programming
to probability physics and calculus so
you can learn new skills explore a
potential career or just stay sharp with
brilliant you can calculate the
probability you'll enjoy this Cinnabon
cinnamon swirl cheesecake and fully
appreciate the beautiful geometry of the
tiramisu after your meal you're going to
need to read up on the mammalian caloric
intake lesson
brilliant makes learning fun and
interactive by teaching through
application you'll solve puzzles riddles
and play games rather than just
memorizing facts click the link on
screen now brilliant.org polymatter to
start your free unlimited 30-day free
trial the first 200 people to do so will
also get 20 off their annual premium
subscription go pick what interests you
most and start learning today